[Música]
Bienvenidos a Londres a este programa
especial sobre los grandes
acontecimientos ocurridos en este 2022
en el Reino Unido la noticia más
importante del año fue el fallecimiento
de la Reina Isabel segunda de 96 años
quien estuvo 70 años en el trono una
monarca universal la mujer más
fotografiada y Famosa del mundo además
de una constante crisis política tras la
destitución del Primer Ministro Johnson
el mandato de un poco más de 40 días de
su sustituta listras y la elección del
actual Premier Richie
[Música]
la Reina Isabel segunda fue protagonista
de la transformación del gran Imperio
británico a lo que es hoy la como un
weld que integran 53 países desde
Inglaterra al Caribe la reina nunca dio
su opinión sobre ningún tema aunque los
grandes asuntos del país pasaron por su
despacho su reinado se caracterizó por
la neutralidad y la estabilidad que le
dio el país en siete décadas de grandes
transformaciones económicas y la
consolidación del Reino Unido como una
potencia mundial su negativo inicial de
permitir un funeral de estado para la
princesa Diana puso tambalear la
estabilidad de la monarquía y los
escándalos personales de su hijo Andrés
fueron uno de sus últimos dolores de
cabeza con la muerte de Isabel inició la
era del Rey Carlos III quien ha
intentado modernizar la monarquía para
garantizar Su futuro
creo que Carlos era un muy buen rey
porque en primer lugar entiende Lo que
implica el papel tuvo que crear su
propio papel como príncipe de gales lo
hizo magníficamente haciendo un trabajo
para benéficas especialmente su
confianza
lo que veremos claramente es alguien que
está por encima de la repliega política
ya que somos políticamente bastante
inestables en este momento pero también
alguien que está comprometido con los
rituales de ser rey promulgar proyectos
de ley abrir el parlamento etcétera
claramente estará respaldado por la
reina Camila
la coronación del rey de 74 años era el
6 de mayo de 2023 se prevé que la
ceremonia estará acorde con la realidad
económica del país
claramente se destacará el hecho de que
hay una crisis económica en Reino Unido
de hecho será una coronación más
reducida pero de todos modos iba a ser
así porque en 1953 cuando se coronó a la
reina Reino Unido era un país
completamente diferente
8000 lo vieron en la abadía Es probable
que sean unos 2000 ahora luego la
ceremonia duró unas tres horas es
probable que sea mucho más corta es
probable que tenga la participación de
otras religiones y en ese momento la
ceremonia también fue lo que lanzó la
televisión y eso te da una idea de lo
que era una era completamente diferente
por lo que obviamente será una ceremonia
muy diferente Pero se mantendrán los
aspectos esenciales los aspectos
religiosos el ritual eso está claro
No menos importante que la muerte de la
reina Isabel II ha sido el terremoto
político que ha sacudido al país por el
paso de tres primeros ministros en solo
un año siendo la crisis y la
inestabilidad política una constante
Boris Johnson fue forzado a renunciar
tras varios escándalos incluido el
partygate listras lo reemplazó de manera
breve su salida llegó tras una crisis
económica de enormes proporciones
impulsada por un plan financiero que
creó pánico en los mercados entre tanto
la llegada de Richie sunak tuvo que
apresurarse y ahora es el primero de
origen indio y el primer billonario en
llegar a Downey
yo creo que los mismos problemas que el
tiene un partido que no están en acuerdo
tiene diputados que quieren una economía
más Todos quieren una economía más
fuerte algunos diputados quieren que la
el estado sea más fuerte más grande y
que en vez está más en la economía otros
diputados quedan una un estado más
pequeño y más ágil y también tiene el
problema
de la crisis del costo de vida a la
inflación los precios del gas y el poder
tiene también el efecto del brexit la
economía sigue un poco más débil a causa
del brexit la disparada inflación que ha
alcanzado récords la crisis en el costo
de vida con las facturas de la luz en
aumento y una economía en recesión
también han sido los protagonistas de
este año tanto el gobierno como los
expertos proyectan tiempos difíciles
para el país tiene un personaje más
tranquilo que el estrés y creo que lo
que necesitamos ahora es un poco de
tranquilidad Así que
puede ser que sale el país o puede ser
que salve la credibilidad de la política
con su tranquilidad pero creo que los
problemas que existen existen ya existen
siguen y no él tiene No tiene otras
ideas para para cambiar el sistema
político para ayudar a la economía el
Primer Ministro es una que ha prometido
recuperar la economía recortando el
gasto público y subiendo los impuestos
mientras algunos tendrán que decidir
entre comer o calentar sus casas en un
invierno que estará marcado por huelgas
de diferentes sectores Gracias por
acompañarnos en esta edición especial
sobre los hechos más importantes
ocurridos en Reino Unido en 2022 siga
con nosotros en France 24 y France
24.com